- Excuse me, can I ask you a question?
Do you believe in love at first sight?
I can walk by again if you want.
(upbeat music)
- Hey y'all my name is Nnenna and
I create videos here at Buzzfeed New York.
So here's the thing, I've always wanted
to initiate conversation with men,
but I'm super duper shy y'all.
But I told myself what is
the worst that can happen?
Rejection.
But I mean that's okay cause life goes on.
Anyway, this video is supposed to be
about me going out into the streets
of NYC to pick up some men.
But I chickened out, I
just couldn't do it y'all.
I can't.
So I decided to get four shy,
but extremely brave
women to do it instead.
Let's watch.
- I'm shy because I'm afraid of rejection.
- When it comes to guys I definitely
have very, very square wheels.
- I'm really, like seriously hoping
to find bae, so fingers crossed.
- I don't think I will ever be ready,
so I'm just gonna go ahead and do it now.
- Is there any rule on
pre-gaming this whole thing?
- Just watching a cop come
by at this exact moment.
- Cheers, let's do this.
- [Male Voice] Wait, wait,
what's going on here?
(upbeat music)
- We found one.
- I feel like we're very
obvious too, just like.
I had a lot of caffeine this morning.
So I'm just like giggly
and jittery in general.
Okay, um.
Hello.
Um, I seem to have lost my number,
can I have yours?
You're really cute, just
thought I'd like to say hi.
Are you single?
Okay, that's okay.
Thanks for putting up with that.
Sorry.
- Hi, excuse me sir, do you have a second?
This is so rough.
Tip number one don't speak to people
when they're on the phone.
(upbeat music)
- Excuse me, do I know you?
Have we met before?
I'm so sorry, I was just confused.
You look a lot like my next boyfriend.
I try.
Alright, have a good one.
- So, love at first sight?
I'm not doing this anymore.
- Hey guys, how are you?
We're good, what are y'all filming?
Handsome stuff?
Continue being handsome.
Yo, live your life.
You too, bye.
I can't, I have to go home.
- Hi, um, kind of weird.
But I think you're really cute.
Do you mind if I get your number?
Sure.
Sorry, I don't ever do this.
Yeah, I do actually.
I don't ever use mine though.
But...
Thank you.
It was nice to meet you Pete.
Yes!
(upbeat music)
- I have a question.
How was heaven when you left it?
No?
- He's like running.
Hey, sorry this is probably really awkward
but I just saw you over
there, and I was like,
oh he's pretty cute.
I was wondering if like maybe
I could get your number?
We could.
Yes.
Jared?
Delisa.
Let's, I'ma check it out.
Perfect.
Got it.
Okay, thank you.
- Jared.
- Nice to meet you Jared.
- Have a good day.
- Absolutely.
- Could have gone a little
bit better probably.
Um...
- It was rough.
- Could have been worse.
- Could have been worse, but
definitely no baes today.
- We did it.
I conquered a fear today.
Today's a good day.
- Yeah, yeah.
(upbeat music)